Dans cette vidéo...
vous verrez un crash d'avion,
un volcan en éruption.
Le naufrage d'un bateau
et des bananes.
Un chien médium,
un chat aux câlins mortels
et des petits petons.
J'ai l'intuition que vous connaissez
le sujet du jour.
Mais principalement,
parce qu'il est déjà écrit dans le titre.
Salut !
Aujourd'hui, on va parler
du sixième sens,
et d'histoires incroyables
de personnes qui ont eu des intuitions
qui ont changé
le cours de leur vie.
Comment peut-on expliquer
qu'il y a des personnes,
ils ont des intuitions si fortes,
qui leur permettent d'échapper
au pire scénario de leur life.
Pourquoi il y a certains animaux,
qui ressentent des choses
avant qu'elles n'arrivent ?
Mais aussi comment développer
votre sens de l'intuition ?
Ce qui implique donc
que l'intuition existe.
Mais tout ça, on va parler
de tout ça dans la vidéo.
Je le précise quand même,
parce que des fois
ce n'est pas très clair pour vous.
Dans la description de la vidéo,
vous avez le chapitrage de toute la vidéo.
Comme ça, s'il y a des parties
qui vous intéressent moins,
vous pouvez sauter
directement sur une autre partie.
ça c'est un truc que j'ai mis en place
depuis septembre 2020,
donc vous pouvez vous y référer
quand vous voulez sauter des parties.
Et je sais que sur les téléphones,
vous pouvez le faire aussi
directement à l'écran.
Voilà, c'était le petit truc en plus.
Likez cette vidéo,
pensez à vous abonner.
Loïc...
- Générique !
- Comment tu savais ?
- Intuition, sixième science...
Science...
Sixième science.
De l'intuition !
- Toi t'es resté en cm2 de l'intuition.
Loïc, générique !
On a tous déjà ressenti
au moins une fois dans sa vie,
ce fameux mauvais pressentiment.
Je crois qu'il y a un truc qui va arriver,
je sais pas te dire comment.
Ou alors au contraire,
le bon pressentiment du :
Là je le sens bien maintenant.
Au fond de nous,
c'est comme une petite voix
qui semble nous guider,
nous aider à prendre des décisions.
Pour certains, ça va être
des petites choses de la vie quotidienne.
Et pour d'autres,
ça va être plus spectaculaire,
comme par exemple,
refuser de monter dans un avion
qui va décoller.
Réussir à rester à terre
et voir que l'avion s'est écrasé.
- Nan, ça c'est Destination Finale !
- Oui et après la mort
les cherche et tout.
Et ça c'est une galère.
Et du coup ils en font six films.
Tout aussi surprenant,
l'histoire d'une jeune fille
qui s'appelle Anne,
et qui grâce on va dire
à sa petite voix intérieure,
a pu avoir la vie sauve.
Et maintenant,
j'ai envie de partager son histoire.
Vous le sentiez arriver ça.
Laissez-moi donc
vous présenter Anne.
Anne décide de partir faire
le tour du monde toute seule.
Et dans son aventure,
elle choisit de faire une petite escale
en Sicile à Palerme,
pour y faire du bénévolat.
Donc Anne est plutôt sympa.
Le 3 juillet 2019,
jour de son anniversaire
qui approche à grands pas.
Elle se dit, je vais faire quelque chose
d'un petit peu plus atypique,
je vais aller faire une rando
sur le volcan Stromboli,
au nord de la Sicile
dans les îles éoliennes.
Rien à voir avec
les éoliennes qui tournent.
C'est pas des îles qui tournent.
Rien à voir.
Comme elle n'a pas envie de passer
sa journée d'anniversaire toute seule,
elle s'inscrit sur une plateforme
de mise en relation
entre voyageurs et gens
qui habitent là-bas, les locaux.
L'idée, c'est de trouver un lieu
à proximité du volcan
pour y dormir quelques jours
avant son anniversaire.
Elle va sur internet.
Elle cherche, elle attend,
elle fait la connaissance de Massimo !
Massimo, qui accepte généreusement
de l'héberger du 1er au 4 juillet.
Et ce qui est marrant,
c'est qu'en plus,
Massimo lui propose de lui-même,
de faire une balade sur le volcan
qu'il connaît comme sa poche.
Alors que dans ses recherches,
elle avait pas encore dit qu'elle voulait
faire une balade sur le volcan.
C'est fou la vie.
Donc tout est organisé
pour son périple à venir.
La veille de son départ
pour le nord de la Sicile,
elle commence à ressentir
quelque chose un peu particulier.
On pourrait dire un malaise
à l'intérieur d'elle-même,
et elle se demande si elle doit vraiment
aller au volcan le lendemain comme prévu,
ou finalement changer ses plans
et rester là où elle est.
En gros, sa raison lui dit
d'aller chez Massimo
parce que tout est organisé,
tout est très sympa, rien à signaler.
Mais son intuition lui dit :
Nada, c'est pas bon.
Du coup elle est hyper embêtée,
parce que tout simplement,
c'est pas dans ses habitudes
d'annuler quelque chose
de manière irraisonnée
du jour au lendemain comme ça.
Et puis sans explication à fournir.
Cette petite voix qui tourne
en boucle dans sa tête,
elle n'arrivera pas à la faire taire.
Elle n'arrive pas à penser
à autre chose que ça.
Alors pour se changer les idées
et pour faire un choix,
elle décide d'aller se balader
de prendre l'air, de marcher un petit peu.
Et là, il y a un homme
qui sort de nulle part,
qui vient vers elle
et qui commence à lui parler
en lui demandant
son prénom, ce qu'elle fait ici.
Et ce monsieur lui dit :
"Il faut absolument aller
à San Vito Lo Capo,
c'est magnifique là bas.
Comme vous pouvez voir sur l'image,
ça a l'air plutôt sympa.
Anne prend cette phrase
comme un signe !
Pas l'oiseau.
Comme un signe de la vie et décide
donc d'annuler le séjour chez Massimo,
et d'aller à San Vito Lo Capo.
Forcément Massimo est déçu,
mais bon ça va, il n'avait pas prévu...
C'était une balade.
Le lendemain,
Anne est complètement apaisée
parce qu'elle sait qu'elle a fait
le bon choix, au fond d'elle.
Mais elle sait toujours pas l'expliquer.
Le 3 juillet, jour où elle devait
se rendre sur le volcan avec Massimo.
Elle reçoit un message
de son oncle, qui lui dit :
"Dis donc, tu as bien a été inspirée
de changer tes plans".
Elle s'est dit :
"Bah c'est à dire ?"
Et bien en effet ce jour là,
le stromboli entre en forte éruption.
Il y a eu un mort, et malheureusement
il s'agissait de Massimo.
Et elle devait être avec lui
ce jour-là, à la base.
C'est un peu ouf
cette histoire quand même.
Alors la grande question :
Est-ce que c'est une intuition ?
Ou est-ce que c'est une synchronicité ?
C'est-à-dire un hasard remarquable.
Un truc qui fait qu'on le remarque.
Si ça se trouve, elle a annulé
plein d'autres choses dans sa vie
où il n'y a pas eu d'éruption non plus.
Mais c'était peut-être pas
sur des volcans non plus.
Le psychologue Guillaume Rabbé,
explique que l'intuition
passe par nos perceptions.
ça se manifeste donc
par nos émotions.
Souvent, il y a un conflit
entre notre logique,
celle qu'on réfléchit,
avec des arguments.
Et notre ressenti
qui passe par l'émotionnel.
Une espèce de dissonance entre notre
cerveau droit et notre cerveau gauche.
Et je fais une petite parenthèse,
des fois vous me dites :
"Oui mais ça existe pas vraiment
le cerveau droit, cerveau gauche".
Oui, j'en parle comme illustration
grosso modo.
Mais j'ai déjà fait une vidéo
sur le fait que,
non il n'y a pas le cerveau droit
qui contrôle toute une partie,
le cerveau gauche
tout l'autre partie.
Bref, fin de la parenthèse.
Une dissonance, donc contre la partie
du cerveau qui gère la raison.
Et l'autre qui gère les émotions.
Et là, elle a plutôt bien fait
d'écouter son ressenti quand même.
Je suis tombé sur une deuxième
histoire qui est tout aussi folle,
si ce n'est plus.
C'est celle de Paul.
Dans les années 80,
Paul s'est lancé dans une aventure
un peu particulière.
Remonter l'amazone
sur un petit rafiot.
Tu fais quoi toi dimanche, Loïc ?
- Je me touche...
- Il faut une fin à cette phrase.
Les orteils, les orteils !
- Les orteils !
- Les orteils, bien sûr !
Et bien pendant que
tu te touches les orteils,
il y en a qui décident de remonter
l'amazone sur un petit rafiot.
Un voyage de 8 jours environ.
Donc dans des conditions
qui sont pas au top, mais de base.
Et vous n'êtes pas
au bout de vos surprises.
Oui, je remets mes lunettes
sans les avoir enlevées.
Un jour, Paul a la mauvaise idée
de manger la viande cuisinée à bord.
Donc sûrement pas très fraîche
et pas très bien conservée.
Et donc, il tombe malade,
il est pris d'une énorme fièvre.
Et c'est pas le seul,
c'est une vraie intox alimentaire.
Donc il y a quelques personnes
sur le bateau,
ils sont tellement intoxiqués
qu'ils meurent de ça.
On parle quand même
d'une grosse intox.
Une nuit, alors qu'il est
complètement fiévreux et délirant,
Paul rêve de sa grand-mère
qui représente pour lui,
une figure maternelle protectrice.
Et dans son rêve,
elle lui recommande
de manger des bananes.
Elle lui dit : "Mange des bananes".
Du coup, lui, il se réveille,
il se souvient de ça,
il mange des bananes
et elles lui redonnent des forces.
Jusque-là,
tout va à peu près bien.
Ce qu'on peut appeler
un remède de grand-mère.
L'équipage avance et arrive
tant bien que mal à Manaus,
qui se situe au Brésil.
Ils arrivent là bas,
même si quand même,
tout le monde se sent
un peu faible et malade.
La nuit suivante,
Paul rêve une fois de plus
de sa grand-mère,
qui lui ordonne
de ne pas prendre le bateau.
En soit, il s'agit que d'un rêve.
Mais Paul a une intuition très forte,
qu'il ne doit pas retourner dans le bateau.
Du coup, il prend l'avion le lendemain
pour rejoindre Brasilia.
Et il s'avère que ce jour là,
un événement fait la une des journaux.
Le naufrage du bateau.
Du bateau que devait
prendre Paul hein.
Avec la mort
d'une dizaine de passagers.
Il témoigne et explique les choses
de cette manière :
"Je pense qu'à l'aller,
j'avais noté inconsciemment
tous les éléments inquiétants du bateau.
Et dans le délire de ma fièvre,
l'image de ma grand-mère,
qui est un symbole chez moi
de protection de mon enfance,
a cristallisé mon intuition
de manière si forte
que je n'ai pu faire autrement
que de suivre cet avertissement.
En tout cas, je n'oublierai jamais
cette histoire".
Et c'est ouf, parce que nous aussi,
du coup on va pas oublier cette histoire.
Mais du coup, ça vient d'où
ce genre d'intuition ?
Voilà quand même un petit élément
d'indique dans sa réponse.
Gerd Gigerenzer,
directeur de l'institut de recherche
Max-Planck à Berlin,
explique que l'intuition,
c'est comme une forme d'intelligence.
Une intelligence qui exploite
les capacités évoluées du cerveau,
qui reposent
sur les méthodes empiriques
qui nous permettent
d'agir rapidement.
Avec une exactitude étonnante.
Notre cerveau donc
connaît pas grand chose en réalité,
a accès à des facultés qui
se développent depuis des millénaires
pour garantir notre survie.
Pour lui, l'intuition serait donc
une forme d'instinct.
Et c'est pas illogique.
Julia Mossbridge,
qui est scientifique
et professeur en psychologie
intégrale et transpersonnelle,
a donné le nom
"d'activité prédictive anticipatoire",
à ce genre
de phénomène d'intuition.
Et tout est dans le nom.
L'intuition serait une forme
d'anticipation et de prédiction.
Des instruments de mesure
indiquent des changements
dans le système respiratoire,
cardiaque et pulmonaire,
quelques secondes avant
qu'un événement dangereux se produise.
C'est un peu comme si le corps
savait inconsciemment
qu'il allait se passer quelque chose.
Par contre, cela s'applique seulement
à une partie de la population.
- Ah mais c'est comme
le "spider sens" !
- Ouais, exactement.
- Spiderman, il a ça,
juste avant il sait !
- J'ai l'impression que ma pizza
va être en retard, exact.
Et si je vous disais que les animaux,
eux aussi, peuvent avoir des intuitions ?
C'est ce qui s'est passé
pour Emma Greset,
qui grâce aux intuitions
de sa chienne joy,
peut anticiper ses propres
crises d'épilepsie.
Voici donc l'histoire d'Emma.
Emma étant épileptique
depuis qu'elle est toute petite.
Les crises d'épilepsie
peuvent se manifester
par des tremblements incontrôlés,
des convulsions,
voire des hallucinations sensorielles
chez certaines personnes.
Et c'est assez handicapant
dans la vie de tous les jours évidemment.
Dès qu'Emma a rencontré ce chien,
un berger australien
dans un élevage canin.
Elle ne savait pas pourquoi expliquer,
elle a choisi ce chien et pas un autre.
Elle a été attirée
instantanément par lui.
Est-ce que c'était un pressentiment ?
On ne sait pas.
En tout cas très rapidement
après avoir adopté le chien,
qui s'avère être
une femelle, donc la chienne.
Elle remarque un comportement
étrange à certains moments.
Emma explique que lorsqu'une
de ses grosses crises d'épilepsie arrive,
Joy, la chienne
se montre très énervée.
Elle la tire par la manche,
par le pantalon,
elle s'accroche à elle,
et commence à lui mordiller bras,
à tourner autour
des gens qu'il y a autour,
à leur tirer les vêtements, etc.
D'ailleurs, lors d'une crise
qui arrivait en pleine nuit,
Joy a tiré sa couette
jusqu'à l'autre bout de la chambre.
Et ça, c'est sa manière
de prévenir Emma
qu'il va se passer
quelque chose de pas cool.
Ce qui est fou,
c'est qu'en moyenne,
Joy la prévient
15 à 20 minutes avant la crise.
Donc c'est pas Joy
qui a commencé à convulser,
la chienne qui voit ça.
Et ça permet au contraire,
à Emma de se mettre dans un endroit
calme en sécurité,
le temps que la crise arrive,
monte et que ça se passe.
De base,
Emma n'avait pas du tout adopté Joy
comme un chien d'assistance.
Mais au fur et à mesure du temps,
ça l'ait devenu à cause
de ses capacités juste incroyables.
- Hey Fabien !
Du coup on peut dire
que cette histoire...
Elle a du chien !
- Et sinon, il y a aussi l'intuition
qui peut annoncer la mort.
Et alors là, c'est moins fun.
Mais assez perturbant
pour qu'on en parle dans cette vidéo.
Vous en avez déjà
peut-être entendu parler.
Il s'agit d'Oscar,
le chat qui prédit les morts.
Depuis plusieurs années,
donc ce cher Oscar accompagne
des patients jusqu'à leur dernier souffle,
leurs derniers moments
dans le centre gériatrique.
Gériatrique ?
Gériatrique !
Steere House à rhode island
aux Etats unis.
Bon il est là,
il vit sa vie de chat.
Et puis d'un coup, il renifle.
Il va rendre visite à un patient,
il se recroqueville à ses côtés.
Et ça, tu te dis :
"Oh il est trop mignon, le petit chat".
Et bien c'est un signe
de la mort imminente de la personne.
Et c'est ce qui pousse les médecins
à appeler les familles
pour organiser une dernière visite,
si jamais vous voulez passer.
Parce que là, c'est...
Et en vrai,
statistiquement le chat aurait reproduit
ce schéma pour 50 patients,
ou plus de 50 patients.
C'est donc pas très hasardeux.
Alors on peut se dire oui,
mais statistiquement
dans une maison de retraite,
un moment donné...
Oui, mais il va pas rendre visite
comme ça tout le temps,
il a pas ce comportement là,
d'une manière générale en fait.
C'est juste qu'à chaque fois
qu'il a ce comportement là,
alors il se passe un décès.
Ah ouais.
Mais après, c'est le deal.
Si c'est ton heure,
c'est ton heure.
C'est-à-dire, que même s'il arrive
dans ta chambre et que tu dis :
Eh bein non,
je me lève, je m'en vais.
Qu'est ce que tu vas faire ?
Bah là c'est Destination Finale.
T'as le chat qui te court après
mais t'y passes quand même.
Alors ça s'explique comment,
ce phénomène d'intuition
chez les animaux ?
Certains chiens seraient
capables de détecter
le changement de rythme cardiaque,
la fréquence respiratoire.
Et certainement de sentir
certaines odeurs qui pour nous, humains,
sont imperceptibles.
Il faut savoir qu'un chien possède
un flair 10 000 à 20 000 fois
plus développé
que celui de l'homme.
Ils sont d'ailleurs en capacité
de détecter des cancers,
puisque les cellules cancéreuses,
émettent moins
de molécules odorantes.
Donc ils voient où est ce qu'il y a
au contraire des manquements d'odeur,
et ils disent :
Ici, là y'a cancer peut-être.
Waouf.
Le chat, quant à lui, a un odora
encore plus développé que le chien.
L'être humain a environ
5 millions de cellules olfactives,
le chien en a environ 150 millions.
Et le chat, plus de 200 millions.
- Complètement "waouf" cette histoire.
- Ouais.
- Par rapport à...
ouf.
- C'est une histoire qui a eu lieu
au milieu, plutôt fin de l'été.
Milieu du deuxième mois de l'été.
Vers la "Miaout".
Donc au final pour les animaux,
c'est un peu d'intuition
avec de la capacité physique.
Mais si ça se trouve,
c'est ces capacités physiques là
que nous appelons l'intuition.
En tout cas c'est assurément
un peu des deux en fait.
Parce que ce sont pas
tous les chats et tous les chiens
qui vous préviennent de tous les dangers
ou d'une mort imminente non plus.
Pour ma part, et sans me baser
sur aucune étude ou aucun travaux,
je crois personnellement
que l'intuition c'est la somme, en fait,
de toute notre mémoire
et toutes nos expériences de vie,
qui ont été accumulées
par le cerveau,
par l'inconscient, par le conscient
dans toute la mémoire.
Et qu'à un moment donné,
il y a une situation qui se présente
et on se fait une déduction inconsciente
de cette situation,
via nos expériences.
Et que notre cerveau
nous envoie un petit :
"Je crois que ça,
je sais pas trop l'expliquer,
mais je crois que ça, parce que
j'ai tous ces schémas là en tête".
Et je pense
qu'on appelle ça l'intuition.
ça ressemble à des choses
qu'on a vécues,
et notre cerveau calcule plus vite
inconsciemment, on va dire,
que les choses
dont nous on a conscience.
Et vous, comment vous pouvez
développer votre petite voix
à l'intérieur de vous,
par exemple ?
- En vous abonnant.
En vous abonnant à la chaîne.
La chaîne !
Abonnez-vous !
- Là par exemple,
vous avez peut-être eu une intuition.
Une bonne intuition
qui pourrait se compléter
avec un truc très raisonnable,
comme le fait d'activer la cloche
pour ne pas rater
les prochaines vidéos.
Ou de liker cette vidéo,
si elle vous plaît.
Voilà, ça c'est un like,
ça c'est un abonnement.
ça c'est une cloche.
Et l'ensemble est gratuit,
donc faites le.
J'ai l'intuition que
ça m'aide pour les vidéos.
Et blague à part, apparemment
l'intuition s'améliore avec l'âge.
Ce qui marche avec
ma théorie de l'expérience.
Plus vous avancez dans le temps,
plus vous assimilez des expériences,
plus votre cerveau est entraîné.
Et puis c'est tout bête
dit comme ça,
mais il faut se faire
confiance un petit peu.
Les personnes très rationnelles
ont tendance à avoir des blocages.
Des espèces de peurs,
d'angoisses, de doutes
qui les empêchent d'écouter
cette petite voix intérieure,
qui est donc un peu irrationnelle,
puisque c'est une conclusion non étayée.
Pourtant, il n'y a rien de magique
dans tout ça.
C'est une sorte de sens
à développer chez soi.
Pour ça, il faut d'abord se libérer
de toutes les idées reçues
et blocages qu'on a
à l'intérieur de nous.
Comme j'expliquais tout à l'heure,
il y a souvent un conflit entre
le rationnel et la partie intuitive.
L'enjeu, c'est de laisser un peu plus
de place à cette intuition
pour la laisser se développer,
sans éteindre le rationnel.
En bref, il faut accorder
de la valeur à cette intuition
quand elle pointe
le bout de son nez.
Et ça commence par
des petites choses du quotidien.
Parce que bon, l'intuition ça veut pas
toujours dire échapper à la mort
ou éviter des situations dangereuses,
heureusement, il y a des intuitions
qui sont moins spectaculaires
mais assez courantes
dans notre vie de tous les jours,
dans le cadre de notre travail, etc.
Et on s'en rend pas forcément
compte dans l'instant,
parce que c'est
un mécanisme automatique.
Par exemple, j'ai l'intuition
que je dois changer de travail.
Je le sens au plus profond
de moi-même.
Je suis pas à l'aise avec ça,
je sais pas dire pourquoi, mais je le sens.
L'intuition, c'est ça aussi.
Lydie Castells,
auteure d'un livre sur le sujet,
explique comment
mettre son intuition en pratique.
On peut d'ailleurs faire de petites
expériences pour tester son intuition.
Par exemple,
en choisissant un bar
pour lequel on a le meilleur ressenti
pour aller boire un verre.
Et voir par la suite,
comment ça se passe sur place
et si ça correspond à notre intuition.
Vous pouvez aussi
faire de la méditation
pour développer cette intuition.
Et puis en plus, la méditation
ça aide à la gestion de la douleur,
comme vous pouvez le voir,
dans une vidéo qui est passée
il y a quelques temps.
L'idée étant d'écouter
ce qui vient de vous
et de se concentrer
sur l'instant présent.
N'hésitez pas à prendre un carnet,
à noter toutes les intuitions
que vous ressentez.
Et d'écrire lorsque ça s'est révélé
être bon ou être mauvais.
Est-ce que vous aviez plutôt bon
ou pas bon dans vos intuitions.
Et j'ai bien envie de vous poser
une autre question.
Dites-moi en commentaire,
quelle est la plus grande intuition
que vous avez jamais ressentie.
Et est-ce qu'elle s'est révélée vraie ?
Moi, il s'est passé quelques trucs,
j'en ai raconté un tout à l'heure à Loïc.
Si vous voulez, je vous la raconterai,
mais ce sera sur mon Instagram.
Alors, non pas que je pourrai pas
le raconter dans la vidéo,
mais c'est la bonne occasion
pour venir me rejoindre sur Instagram.
Il est là, c'est celui-ci là.
Voilà.
Qui n'a rien à voir avec celui là,
qui est celui de Loïc.
Ou encore celui là,
qui est celui de Fanny
qui m'a donné
tous les noms aujourd'hui,
parce que j'en ai marre
de ne pas savoir les prononcer.
Si vous ne me connaissez pas,
je m'appelle toujours Fabien Olicard.
Si vous me connaissez,
Parce que je reçois des messages
pour Sébastien ou Olivier.
Mais moi c'est Fabien Olicard,
c'est pas Sébastien.
C'est pas Olivier.
Ici, je vous mets deux autres vidéos.
ça c'est une vidéo
sur trois personnes
qui sont devenues des génies
du jour au lendemain.
Vous verrez, c'est très surprenant.
Et là je vous mets
une vidéo sur quoi, Loïc ?
- Oui ?
- Sur quoi cette vidéo ?
Sur la gestion de la douleur,
parce que je venais d'en parler.
Et bien voilà, c'est une vidéo
qui est sortie il n'y a pas longtemps,
vous pouvez regarder ça.
Prenez très soin de vous,
A très bientôt.